So your awesome mobile game
seems to be doing pretty well,
but users are complaining
about load time.
After some profiling, the
problem soon becomes clear.
You're spending too much
time deserializing your data.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
we can make your data loading
experience faster for
users and easier for you
with the new
flatbuffers library.
As you already know,
loading your content
is a really gnarly process.
All of the data that comes from
your content creation tools
like physics, animations,
spreadsheet data,
have to all be stored
in some sort of format
that you can load into your
game and ship to customers.
And this is even counting
the temporal stuff,
like sending your game data
across a network connection
or saving your game
to be reloaded later.
Since this process is so
critical to game development,
how do we go about optimizing
it for performance?
To do that, let's go
back to the basics.
Serialization is the process
of taking some in-memory data
structure and converting it into
a data format which, one, can
be converted back to
the in-memory structure
at some point in the future
and, two, be somewhat
compact in order to not
take up too much space.
Now, some of the more popular
serialized formats out there
are XML and JSON, mainly
because they are human readable.
That is, you can actually open
these files into a text editor,
poke around, make changes,
and actually understand
what you're doing.
And this popularity is further
extended with native support
in languages like C#,
Java, and JavaScript.
But in truth, these formats come
with some serious drawbacks.
Firstly, they tend
to be bloated.
The fact that these
formats are human readable
means there's lots of
overly verbose syntax
that's added to the format
for the ease of readability
and use, making the file larger
than it actually needs to be.
Secondly, the overly inflexible
nature of these formats
puts an enormous strain on
the deserialization process.
The parsing system has
to read in string data
and then run analysis
on it in order
to determine what data type
it is before converting it
to that actual type in memory.
And this gets worse when
your format supports
more advanced types like GUIDs,
timestamps, and date objects.
The result is a deserialization
process that's anything
but fast once complexity
hits a certain level.
To address these problems,
we've released a new open source
tool for games
called flatbuffers.
This library prides itself
going back to the basics
for serialization, that
is, being fast for encoding
and decoding while also
producing the smallest
encoded file possible.
Now, at a high
level, flatbuffers
work by creating a file that
describes the data types to be
serialized, called a
schema, and then this
is handed over to a
syntax compiler that
produces code files that you
can include in your application
to encode and decode from the
formats that you've defined.
Since your in-game structures
tend to be complex,
the schema format that
you feed into the compiler
allows you to describe
your data structures
using type primitive relations,
for example, objects reusable
classes, enums, and
very basic types.
This layout allows
flatbuffers to be type safe,
and further allows you to read
from the serialized data format
without having to do any
type conversions, memory
allocations, or unpacking
during load time, which
is a huge speed boost.
Once you've created
your schema files
for all your
serializable data, you
feed those schema files
into the flat C compiler
to generate source code
files for your game.
With the right
command line switches,
you can either
generates C++, Java,
or even Go code files that you
can drop right into your repo
and compile against.
Now, regardless of what language
you're actually programming in,
using flatbuffers to load
data is pretty simplistic.
Given your serialized
stream of bytes,
pass it off to a
single line of code
to convert it into
your desired object,
and then you're ready
to start using it.
Now, that's all fine and
dandy, but how fast is it?
Let's take a look at
how flatbuffers compare
to a few other options, namely
protocol buffers and JSON.
We can see that with respect to
both decode and encode times,
flatbuffers outperform
the other formats
by a significant factor.
In fact, when stacked
up side by side,
you can't see the flatbuffers
time on the graph.
Hmm.
Now, just as important is the
encoded size of the test data.
You can see that within
extremely fast encode
and decode times
flatbuffers are minimal when
it comes to both the
original size of data
as well as the zlib
compressed versions.
Oh, and one more thing.
You know how when you change
the data formats of your game
and it creates a
massive chaos vortex
with older formats, live
builds, and compatibility?
Flatbuffers don't
have that problem,
as they provide functionality
to evolve your schemas
without affecting compatibility
in older data and older
programs, which is pretty
cool in my opinion.
Of course, there's tons
of great other features
in the projects left to explore.
To learn more about the
flatbuffers library,
or if you want more info on
what's going on under the hood,
check out the
flatbuffers Docs page
and then hop on over to grab
the code at our github repo.
Serializing your data
shouldn't be a pain.
Now go out there and
build better games.
Better games-- did we
write that to rhyme?